yeah there are two microphones here and
as the controller he turn it on when I
went when you want and Emily listen and
over the last time in this session is by
where the co-organizers so he doesn't
need any introduction a new store and
he's gonna be talking about
approximating graph isomorphism through
linear map okay um I'll skip the usual
thanking the organizers so like it says
this is based on joint work with the
former student brt home some of this
appeared in a paper arm back in my cup
2012 on where we looked at partition
game so that's not the perspective that
you'll see in this talk a sort of longer
journal version of that paper is just I
think just appeared about to appear and
there's some other unpublished work
mainly I want to sort of get through a
whole lot of somewhat technical
definitions i hope i don't for you to
get to the end tool what i think are
some interesting questions on and
perspectives on ongoing work okay so
graph isomorphism we all know this
without we all know what what it means
to decide graph isomorphism and it's a
problem of great interest because its
complexity is somewhat interesting right
neither NP complete nor known to be in p
but now known to be in Kwazii polynomial
time so my point of view the in terms of
complexity graph isomorphism is
completely equivalent to the following
problem where you're given a single
graph g and two vertices and you ask is
there is there an autumn or FISMA g
which takes you to be ok and i will kind
of free even without saying it switch
between these two perspectives there
from my point of view that the same
problem and in fact many algorithms
which are used for testing graph
isomorphism do this but they really do
is given a graph they come up with a
vertex partition like that I was just
talking about and what we want is a
vertex partition that quickly get a
partition which sort of approximates the
partition of vertices into orbits of the
automotive ism group right I mean full
full fledged algorithm would give you
the full partition but like the color
refinement algorithm very quickly gives
you an approximation okay more generally
you know like the K dimensional by
spider demon you partition not the
vertex vertex set to the set of cables
for example again you are trying to
approximate the partition of VK into the
orbits of the autumn of the action of
the automorphism group on VK right
I'm very quickly going to run through a
color refinement because Sandra's
already given so much so kind of
refinement also known as one-dimensional
Vice father Damon gives you for a graph
a partition of the vertices and you can
say along with constant C IJ for each IJ
for a pair of pair of parts so that
every vertex in p.i has exactly CIJ
neighbors in PJ ok so it partitions it
so that this kind of condition is
satisfied that there exists concept of
constant satisfying this equality ok in
fact it gives you the coarsest partition
satisfying I mean we have a partition we
have what i call a stability condition
and what we get is the algorithm gives
us the quartus courses partition
satisfying the stability condition and
you can see it arrives at by a sequence
of refinement of equivalence relations
you troll start with the trivial
equivalence relation or the equivalence
relation into the initial color colors
and then you successively refine the
partition until it stabilizes and we
know it stabilizes in at most n steps
and you know each iteration is easy to
compute so this makes it a faster
algorithm
oh yeah okay
let's see what doesn't show up okay the
K dimensional vice vitamin aims at a
partition of the k tuples of vertices
perfect value of K right okay that's
interesting that's a that that is a
bold-faced you okay but but it'll do as
long as it's consistent so we have a
partition and we're going to define now
what the stability condition is what
when is a partition stable we do this by
saying take any k tuple and we look at
it as inducing a labeling of the
vertices what's the labeling of the
vertices it decides for every vertex at
a tuple of numbers each one of these is
between 1 and M where if you take the
tuple and you substitute in the Jays
position this vertex a the resulting k
pupil is in part i J okay so this gives
the labeling for every vertex and each
vertex is labeled by a k2 full of
numbers right telling you which
equivalence classes you end up in and
then the K dimensional vice valid even
finds the courses partition that if you
have two tuples now back to you and
that's a V yeah this is a looks guy
makes the condition trivial but
if you have you and be there in the same
part then order independence so about
semen okay when you have a pair of
tuples then for every possible label
right the number of vertices satisfying
that label with respect to you is the
same as the number of vertices
satisfying that label with respect to V
ok that's the stability condition ok and
so what a dimensional types are they
leave an algorithm does is find you the
coarsest partition of VK which is finer
than the refinement into atomic types so
you start with k tuples you refine them
into their topic types look at just the
sub graph induced by that K tuple that
gives you a partition that's your
starting point and then you find the
course courses partition which satisfies
the stability condition ok and the point
is again as we pointed out it stabilizes
in at most n to the K iterations and
computing each iteration is something
order n to the K maybe into the k plus 1
and so for a fixed value of K this is a
polynomial time Alan yeah I think I have
all that on a slides right so what do we
know two graphs are indistinguishable by
K dimensional vice file and even if and
only if they're not distinguished by any
sentence of CJ plus 1 right so this is
the connection with logic ck + wanting
first-order logic with k plus 1
variables and counting 1 2 5 so this
characterizes equivalents in this logic
as I said it can be decided an end to
the some constant times K because you
start with the partition into atomic
types they refine this is what I just
said basically right at each stage
computing the labeling takes time n to
the K + 1 because they're n to the K
vertices in the new you you iterate over
all so the n to the K tuples and the new
iterate over all vertices and what's
interesting is that this K dimensional
equivalence relation we get
or this equivalence relation on grass
defined by the K dimensional Vice
parliament has many equivalent
characterisations i mentioned
characterization in logic there's a
characterization in terms of pebble
games in fact more than one there's
characterization in terms of linear
programming hierarchies of this family
this is a work number of people that
serious medieval martin grow and mark
not all have a follow up so linear
programming relaxing or lift and project
hierarchies on on top of the linear
programming relaxation of isomorphism or
fractional isomorphism algebras of
complex matrices this is the original
definition by Vice filer n lehman was in
terms of complex algebras actually what
they define is what we now would call
the two-dimensional vice valid even it
is really Bob I who took that pulled out
the combinatorial content and
generalized at 2k dimensions and he gave
it the name k-dimensional vice fire
element method so I think I mean Bob I
should get the credit for this but in
fact you can go back and take the K
dimensional version and recast it in
terms of complex matrices and this is
part of what what BRK and I did as well
okay now
I read wln for Vice Valley limit of n to
not the smallest k so that for any to
end vertex graphs k equivalence it
implies isomorphic right in for any pair
of graphs if you go to dimension large
enough right at most n you need at most
the number of vertices then
k-dimensional vaisala Lehman equivalence
is isomorphism so what is the smallest k
that works for all n vertex rafts well
that's like you're a merman need all
those yeah sorry the Cybermen results
tells us that this function is bounded
below by a linear function of him okay
so you need order of n dimension to
characterize isomorphism in and verdicts
in particular this means that if you use
the vice file read even as a generalized
some morphism algorithm to work on all
of grass then the complexities n to the
end right n to the order n which is
pretty bad ok it's I mean you may as
well I mean I to the order and is the
same order as n factorial you can just
you know as emphatically its is the same
as trying all possible permutations and
seeing if any of them is an isomorphism
and we know thanks to well we already
knew that before babas recent
breakthrough but you know you could do
better than that you know to to the
square root of n now we know we can do
it in to the polygon again ok um
and what cipher mmm and these these
people do is give a construction of
pairs of graphs with order K vertices
which are non isomorphic but
indistinguishable right i mean exactly
what the what it says and these can be
chosen to be three regular and color
class size 40 i'm not going to say a lot
more about that in this town okay now i
want to generalize this idea of an
iterated partition refinement a little
bit okay so we have a partition of VK
pick about your fellow smaller than king
and just just I mean I know this gets a
bit technical so just to keep in mind
this is a generalization in the Vice
Fire Emblem inversion l is one in the in
the general k dimension and take the set
of all injective functions from l2 k now
each tuple induces the labeling not just
of vertices which is what we had before
in the case l equals 1 but of alkyl
pools basically you pick a pig and I'll
tuple and look at all ways of
substituting it for LOL elements in the
k2 pool and then you look at what
equivalence class you get and always of
substituting is given by taking the set
of all injective functions that was the
idea right you have an LTL you want to
look at it we have substituted inside
the cake Cuba so
so the labeling takes an L couple to
this tuple which is a map from F into em
right the one which takes a an element f
of capital F to the equivalence class or
I mean the label of the part which you
get by substituting be beautiful in
there okay I mean this is complicated
enough without having these things now
so this just says what a labeling is I
mean this is this is completely generic
you define some notion of equivalence
between labelings the notion of
equivalence in the Vice final diamond
case was simply that we the sizes the
cardinalities were the same of e of each
label set okay but if you have some
notion of equivalence we get some notion
of stability of the partition the
partition is staying okay so three
things the value of K the value of L and
thus notion of equivalence define the
coloring scheme right in the Vice valid
even case k is the dimension l is one
and this equivalence is just the label
parts or all of the same size okay so
given this three things we can define
the coarsest partition that is stable
again you know let's say refining the
partition into atomic types and just on
purely combinatorial grounds the number
of steps of iteration to get to the
stable partition must be at most n to
the K because they are n to the K 2
tuples each step is performing a
refinement sep so we have an upper bound
so as long as the each refinement step
in polynomial time we had a polynomial
time algorithm right as long as each
refinement step okay and we have a
polynomial time computable equivalence
relation which is some approximation if
i sum or fizzle okay now I want to look
at
a couple of variants of this by defining
suitable equivalence relations for all
values of K and L the motivation comes
from this logic fixed point with rank
right so the ck ck equivalences or the K
dimensional vice file and even
equivalences we're very useful in citing
the logic fixed point with counting and
in particular the cipher remember and
construction showed us that fixed point
with counting is insufficient to give us
all of polynomial time this is what
motivated the introduction of fixed
point with rank what sort of equivalence
relations can we use to study the limits
of the expressive power of fixed point
with rank well
in particular site where membrane graphs
I mean this is just motivating why rank
logic I'm not going to define the logic
I know people have some people have
referred to this like greg did in this
talk yesterday but what we know is for
instance we can distinguish the Cybermen
graphs of our reduction to systems of
linear equations / GF 2 in particular
there's a definable matrix which you
pick the same definition in gk + HK and
you get you get a matrix / GF 2 which
has distinct rank this is what sort of
motivated the extension of first-order
logic to with operators for rank that's
the reference so I'm not going to find
the logic here but I'm going to look at
what equivalence relation that induces
ok and then that turns out to be not
very useful in particular not
retractable equivalence relation sorry
it turns out to be not retractable
equivalence relation so we will actually
come up with friendly enough a
strengthening of it something that makes
more distinctions but is tractable and
then I want to ask some questions about
that ok so in the case of matrix rack
partition so we have a partition of DK
we have the notion of labeling for some
value of L and I'm going to assume Mel
is even ok
I didn't think of this labeling
mislabeling remember just science to
each lq pull some value from one floor
I don't know I have an R over here and I
so we went to no no no no okay that's
gonna be in general be okay so it
assigns yeah the lightning a sign
sweetie el tuple not a single value one
through our but essentially a tuple of
values right from 1 through our one for
each injective function from ltk that's
the best point ok so the signs to each
tuple a label I basically can think of
this as a collection of matrices 01
matrices vm to vm right because the
labeling is a partition of V to the 2m
for each part i construct the matrix
where put a 1 if that the particular 2m
pupil is in the part and 0 otherwise so
this is a collection of matrices which
if you add them up you'll get there once
matrix because it's a partition of the M
times V M according to the lately now I
define that what is the notion of
equivalence of two labelings basically
we want to get them gather the idea that
these pupils you and you prime are
distinguished by a formula Frank logic
and that turns out to be equivalent to
saying there is some linear combination
of these matrices so that the same
linear combination of those matrices
gives you something of different rank ok
if this is true you can construct a
formula in rank logic to distinguish
them so we want to do this and if it's
false then you can't so this is our
stability condition right our partition
is stable if basically whenever two
things are equivalent there is no such
thing that distinguishes them okay now i
said this rank now your question is
which rank function are we looking at
and the point is we in the logic we're
going to have ranked operators for
various prime prime fields so you
consider a you know all of them well
specifically you fix the value of K and
fix any set of prime numbers and we get
an equivalence relation where when you
look at these ranks of linear
combinations you take
okay so course is partition so that is
two things are equivalent and you look
at these two labelings then for any
prime P and Omega and any linear
combination these ranks are equivalent
when you look at the rank in the field
GF p okay as I said this is the sort of
technical bit of the definition we we
get to but this defines a notion of
equivalents which really captures
equivalents in the rank logic it's
refines vice file eliminate coblentz
right you need baby to add to but pretty
much any non empty Omega will do over
there and it properly refines it because
you look at these Cybermen graphs g KH k
there can be distinguished using
dimension 3 and just the prime you know
just the prime number two so there is a
distinction in fact we can show that on
color graphs of chemical I size for
which in within which this I promo and
graphs fall this thing is already a test
for isomorphism it distinguishes all non
isomorphic groves is it freezing a movie
if the number of variables you need in
the rank logic exactly right ah ok
now what lower bounds can we prove we
can prove that basically you need all
the primes methods if you take any set
omega and a P which is not in there we
can construct a pair of round isomorphic
graphs that are equivalent its variant
of the cfi construction that modulo Pira
the modular two in my paper with the b
arky home we really did it for the case
l equals 2 i think the general case
should follow from work by grade olympic
kusa though we have it i mean there's
some work to the weed i'm to attract
from your construction an actual example
of graph like this but i think it can be
done ok the trouble is it's not clear
that this equivalence relation is
actually decidable in polynomial time
right I told you it is defined by a
sequence of refinement steps each step
it's the number of refinement steps is
at most n to the K but at each step you
have to check for a pair of labelings
and for n to the 2k pairs of tuples Oh
whether there that's right whether the
labelings are equivalent but the
equivalent labeling means you have to
look at all in your combinations of
these late disease and their
exponentially many of them potentially
exponentially many the number of linear
combinations is what's what's the
obstacle here we don't know how to get
around this but it turns out we can
actually further strengthen this
equivalence relation to get something
even tighter closer to isomorphism but
which is tractable and what we do there
is we define a partition I mean so now
that we're somewhat removed from the
rank logic but we fix we have a fixie
dimension K and we fixed a set of prime
numbers Omega and we define the
following the equivalence relation we
have take the coarsest partition so that
if two tuples are equivalent and you
construct the the tuples of matrices but
we had before exactly the same I mean
you look at the labeling as two tuples
of matrices and you ask for any p is
there an invertible matrix that
individually takes each alpha
could be dying or I'll fight you to me
today the thing is if there is such an
invertible matrix then obviously any
linear combination of these has the same
linear combination has the same rank as
the corresponding linear combination
there so that's a strengthening but it
turns out that this test is testable in
polynomial time it's not right so this
is what I just said it's not obvious but
there is a result of these guys all
right this is just shift stop at all
which guarantees that this condition
which is called the simultaneous
similarity of matrices is testable in
polynomial time by reduction to module
isomorphism and then they give a they
give an algorithm for that so that means
that the refinement steps to to arrive
at the stable partition with respect to
this can be performed in polynomial time
and therefore this is a polynomial time
decidable equivalence relation and it
gives us a limitation on rank logic
right anything in rank logic cannot
distinguish between these we don't know
the other direction we could get the
other direction if we could show that
this algorithm was itself implementable
in fixed point with rank but we don't
know that ok oh
maybe I mean just because we have too
many parameters here we could simplify
it and just say well when we're looking
at n Verdex crafts just throw in all
Prime's less than or equal to n and we
have an equivalence relation now is just
depends upon the dimension K and it is
decidable in the end to the big o of K
ok so now here here I I get two
questions what do we know about this
like with the Vice Parliament let's ask
for the smallest value of K so that this
I suppose I should have on the guy in
over here but so that the K dimensional
equivalence relation gives you
isomorphism on an end vertex rocks I
have nothing to say about this you know
the trivial bounds it's very constant
and linear I mean if we could prove
obviously a constant upper bound we have
a polynomial time algorithm for graph
isomorphism if you could prove a poly
logarithmic upper bound we have an
alternative to Baba is quazy polynomial
time algorithm if you could prove a
linear lower bound we have some really
significant youtube for proving and
express ability in the in the logic ok
so knowing something in between this
would be very useful I have some ideas
on how to analyze it we're very
preliminary this is work up doing with
Joanna who's back there and that is you
look at these witness for the stable
partition you look at these invertible
matrices which which witness this they
form a subgroup of the of this general
in your group and really the question
we're asking is for what values of K
does this collection of groups as as you
Barry p actually determine the
automorphism group of the of the graph
all right and so there seems to be a
purely groups here at a question here
which we're trying to pin down ok last
couple of minutes I want to make a
connection to see ESPYs you since that
popped up
so we know another way of saying two
graphs are isomorphic of course is to
say that there's a pair of formal
homomorphisms this should be from HTG
right pair of alma morphisms in each
direction which are mutually inverse
okay so that you know composing them
gives you the b2 identity maps following
prakash's motto categoric i right in
practice as we more mentioned you know
Lord deciding homomorphism is often done
by a sort of K local consistency test in
logical terms k local consistency can be
described as saying let's say G K maps
to H if any existential positive
sentence or a PP formula in his
terminology with at most K variables
sorry gah got switched to a and B
somewhere if G satisfies right which is
true in G it's ruining this has the
disick this relation right the gk maps
to H has a nice bubble game
characterization due to color a decent
party let's category that by defining
Amy you can define a notional strategy
composition right which says that if you
have a strategy from g2h and a strategy
in in the capable game from h2k you can
compose them into a strategy from g2h
and now what's the notion I mean in this
category watch the notion of isomorphism
right when you have a pair of strategies
which are mutually inverse it's exactly
K dimensional vice fighter Lehman right
it just falls out so the question I want
to ask is we now have an invertible map
equivalents which is stronger than this
we work our way back what is the right
notion of homomorphism that gives us
right it should be something powerful
than k local consistency and hopefully
something tractable but I don't know
what so this is a question I want to
throw out because I think it links to
the CSP okay and I'll stop there so the
simultaneous diagonalization or
something similarity is it like is there
some similar jordan 4 matrices or how is
it done is it algebraic yes no it's not
so much algebraic and I don't remember
but I can I think these things are very
studied in classic algebras yes yes yes
yes well but let's from the algorithmic
point of view and we were very keen on a
polynomial time algorithm for it and the
algorithm as I remember I mean there's
more than one around and I haven't
looked at them all I mean this one was
though from about 97 this is my chest
over at all which I and I think there is
another one more recent that I've been
meaning to look at so so yes I theory
1 2 circles to solving isomorphic
problem play by quantum algorithm in
this connection this the original vice
favor of neiman approach with the
complex matrices yeah how much of your
development in the original approach so
so no that's why we look we looked at
that and actually you can this
invertible map equivalent me define you
can sort of see as taking the original
vice file 11 and replacing the complex
field by finite fields and it actually a
pair of surprisingly gives you something
more powerful right because this is a
and so we can we can describe this I
mean it's a bit trickier because I mean
the complex field is much better behaved
in particular these coherent algebras
which you get from the complex field in
the vise firearm a new construction or
semi simple algebra which we don't get
once you start with a finite field and
so there there that ever I mean this is
some things fall apart but you can
describe this this equivalence as I said
taking the the device filer Lehman and
replacing the complex field by finite
fields and this finite characteristic it
seems to be exactly the power that
allows you to distinguish the cybermen
graphs for example
okay those who have so many people here
I just want to make an announcement
again which is that if if you gave a
talk you're already already on your
video is up but it's very important to
add your slides otherwise we hard to
follow send your slides to Pamela if
you're giving a talk and and you're
going to collective sludge say what
especially connect to those what more
you can do this like we can
automatically anonymize your slots of
you okay thank you very much